hi there Steve here day five I think it
is today I'm going to talk about
dictionaries and by the way please send
your questions via Twitter or Facebook
apparently doesn't work here on YouTube
with the hashtag link challenge and we
will select someone who for whatever
reason I think get random four or five
minute or 15 a 15-minute interview with
me in the language of their choice to
discuss whatever is an interest to them
dictionaries um obviously we need
dictionaries if we're reading material
that has words we don't know I've said
many times I don't like looking things
up in a traditional dictionary because
it takes too long when you forget right
away part of the reasoning behind link
is that we have instant access to an
online dictionary in fact you can choose
the online dictionary that you prefer
and thereafter that weird is highlighted
in yellow it and helps you to remember
it and so forth and so on problem with
Korean is that dictionaries don't work
so well the worst is google translate
google translate is pretty good for
slavic languages in polish it's
remarkably good and not only for
individual words but also for phrases so
that in polish i'll look up some
individual words i don't get the sense
of the phrase i put the phrase to google
translate and i understand the meaning
excellent i think it's a function of how
much material google has or whatever
system they use for generating this
translation in korean the results we get
off google translator just ridiculous
they usually four phrases are very poor
and even for individual words is often
wrong it's wrong so often that I can't
rely on google translate so I go to
neighbor neighbor appears to be the best
Korean dictionary but very often there
is no translation or Dave neighbor has a
bunch of sentences and doesn't give you
they see on a random basis either they
translate the word they just have a
bunch of sentences and you
left trying to read through these
sentences and trying to figure out which
of these words actually is the word the
translation for the word that you're
looking up I do use neighbor to select
the Chinese character which I put into
my hint so anyone following after me
will see the Chinese character for the
word so I mean I use neighbor because
there is nothing else but very often
there is absolution I have never it you
know I'm struggling through these
difficult texts for example these
podcasts that I've had transcribed which
I have a lot of in which we've put in
the linked library so we have wonderful
audio and text if that were polish or
Ukrainian or something German i think
i'd be much further ahead because i
would be able to use google translate
and i would be getting instant you know
meanings for the words that i encounter
that I don't know but it is a struggle
with Korean google translate's know
essentially not usable and neighbor is a
bit hit-and-miss and and then i have to
go to the additional step of selecting
the chinese character which i don't have
to do much what which I tend to do
because I find it helps me so for all of
those reasons it's a little slower for
me doing Korean than the other languages
so just a bit of a discussion on
dictionaries I'd be interested in your
comments bye for now